[Música]
o sol só vez mais no vídeo e hoje usa
demonstração de minha última arma que é
essa aqui estão dois modelos baseados no
marco da primeira guerra mundial que
congrega não estou lembrado novo
provavelmente está no título deste dia
especial tem estridência é muita
resistência por ter um tripé para mim a
gente parar por cima para baixo e para
os lados dessa maneira e quando vocês
quiserem disparar basta clicar aqui e
falar nada porque não tem lá senhora
força isso é muito bom para estar em
alta enquanto eu e depois vamos para a
demonstração bola
[Música]
o software do time espero que vocês
tenham gostado do dia do vídeo só deixar
seus documentários três comentários de
água de seus projetos nos comentários e
coisas milhões
é isso que importa espanha até próximo
do ideal
[Música]